séances de tir à l'arc aujourd'hui à vil
prix pour camille cette mère de deux
enfants de 38 ans veut se perfectionner
pour participer en fin d'année au raid
des amazones cette compétition 100 %
féminine créée en 2001 réunira en
décembre 270 femmes en thaïlande avec au
programme des épreuves sportives
c'est un rêve déjà dans l'idée de se
dépasser un peu de vivre une aventure
épanouissante
enfin voilà sortir un petit peu de notre
routine foisonne de confort c'est du
challenge
il ya l'aspect voyage qui est important
car il ne partira pas seul en asie la
ville procès ne partagera cette aventure
avec son amie emilie 33 ans résidente du
puy de dôme
on s'entend très très bien après la
distance nous séparent quand même parce
qu emilie elle vit à clermont ferrand
et puis moi j'ai été amené à emménager
en région parisienne mais on se connaît
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
on est amis et voilà c'est l'entente
entendre parfaite pour réussir à
performer le jour j la ville proviennent
veut associer cette entente parfaite un
programme sportif rigoureux elle peut
s'entraîner jusqu'à six fois par semaine
hier alors c'est un peu exceptionnel
mais j'ai fait un triathlon j'ai fait 72
flèches de tir à l'arc j'ai fait 6 km
300 de course à pied j'ai enchaîné avec
12 km de vélo c'est assez exceptionnel
pour moi
malgré tout ce qui est important pour
s'entraîner pour se préparer à fred
c'est d'arriver à enchaîner des séances
de sport quotidiennement sur plusieurs
jours consécutifs avec ses entraînements
camille espère pouvoir tenir
physiquement sur les six jours de course
et pourquoi pas terminer le plus haut
possible ce raid avec sa coéquipière